As I've mentioned to you before,
each of the three aspects of experience,
so the things you know,
the things you don't know and the fact
of yourself have a very ambivalent
underlying structure,
both positive and negative so that the
things you don't know are interesting
and compelling and the sources of new
information,
but also the source of the things that
undermine you both physically and
mentally and the things you know.
Of course your culture disciplines you
and shapes you into a full person,
but also at exactly the same time molds.
Zealand crushes you in a particular
direction rather than any of the other
directions you might have gone in.
And then finally with regards to the
individual,
we spent a substantial amount of time
discussing the individual's capability
capacity to make order out of chaos and
sometimes to make chaos out of order in
the service of a higher order and that's
all to the good,
but just like culture and nature have
there negative aspects.
So do the individual and I think
personally this is where Christian
mythology in particular comes into its
own.
I think of all the major religions,
Christianity has the most thoroughly
developed what you might describe as
formal model of evil,
and that model isn't part of the
canonical writings of Christianity,
say encapsulated in the Bible,
but part of the cloud of sort of
unnatural mythology and storytelling
that surrounds the canonical writings,
so you could say that although
Christianity and Buddhism has spent a
substantial amount of time developing up
a representation of the hero,
Christianity in particular has also
spent a substantial amount of time
developing a formal portrait of the
figure that stands in opposition to the
hero and I think the most appropriate
term for that figure who takes multiple
forms in mythology is the adversary
because
the adversarial spirit is a spirit that
stands in opposition to to everything
stands in opposition to nature,
stands in opposition to culture,
and most specifically stands in
opposition to that aspect of the human
being.
That's both exploratory and creative.
Now,
the last time we talked,
I had a chance to describe to you how
the figures of the adversarial brothers
emerged naturally at the end of genesis
as a,
as a Coda to the story,
right?
Adam and eve developed self
consciousness.
They develop knowledge of their own
mortality and death and as the
primordial parents of humanity,
their first children take the form of
the hostile brothers,
which is to say that if you're the child
of nature and the child of culture,
the sort of ultimate parents,
then as an individual,
you take two forms,
a positive form in a negative form,
and the negative form is characterized
in many ways by a kind of absolute
hatred of the good hatred of the
positive form.
And I think that you can't understand
the full human propensity for evil
without considering more than the
territory,
lot more than the innate territoriality
of human beings.
So if you look at animals,
well,
animals are territorial and they fight
to preserve their territory and it's
irrational struggle.
They're fighting for resources and for a
place that they can that they can
operate and live in and reproduce in
efficiently.
But human beings are substantively
different from that,
in that there are agonistic conflict.
Their aggression often seems to be
motivated by something more akin to the
pure desire for destruction rather than
for any rational landlord.
So ever.
And so from that perspective,
I would say as an example,
the fact that Hitler ended up committing
suicide in a bunker beneath Germany's
capital at the end of the Second World
War when Berlin was in flames when all
of Germany was in flames and when his
country was completely defeated,
after tens of millions of people had
died in the conflict,
including of course the 7 million or so
people that were killed in the
Holocaust.
The normal mode of interpretation of
that would be what a terrible defeat for
Hitler.
But an equally valid.
And I think an equally valid prima facie
argument.
And one I think that's actually more
valid is that it wasn't a defeat for
Hitler at all.
It was precisely what he was aiming at
right from the beginning because his
mode of being was intensely adversarial.
And I would also say that it's certainly
possible that the full nature of his
motivations weren't even necessarily
clear to him as they unfolded across
time during the Second World War.
No more than the full motivations of any
human being are necessarily accessible
to them as they act out,
whatever it is that they act out.
So Carl Jung says,
for example,
that we act out great mythological
stories.
That doesn't necessarily mean you know
the story,
it just means he act it out.
So for example,
you see people whose lives are
repetitive bouts of tragedy and what
they're acting out is a tragic story and
they know it in so far as they're
actually acting it out,
but they don't necessarily have an
explicit model of the relationship
between their patterns of behavior and
the constantly tragic outcomes they
produce.
Well,
that doesn't even necessarily mean that
what they're doing isn't voluntary
because things can be voluntary even if
you don't understand them fully.
There's an aspect to the human psyche
that's a nest of vipers,
so to speak,
because you can't necessarily trust what
you see.
And that means not only when you're
looking at someone else say,
but even when you're looking in the
mirror,
you can't be sure that what you say
you're doing is exactly what you're.
Your motivations aren't transparent and
they may not even be clear.
So I suppose the idea that lurks behind
this formalization is that freedom of
choice is such a good that one of its
subsidiary necessities,
which is that there has to be a polar
distinction between good and evil is
worth having.
Freedom is so important that it
justifies the distinction between good
and evil.
And I think that art,
I think that's a reasonable way to
presume
it's reasonable to presume that that's
the manner in which experience is
actually structured and there's complex
reasons for that.
One would be that under the most optimal
circumstances,
which is something we'll talk about as
this proceeds to a close,
that means in a sense you can have your
cake and eat it too,
which means the potential existence of
good and evil allows for freedom of
choice.
And then if the choice is always towards
the good,
then you have the benefits of freedom.
Of choice plus the benefits of the good,
the only price you have to pay is the
constant possibility of evil.
It's very much like the structure of
Christianity,
so you have the highest God whose whose
highest son is Christ,
but you have the figure of Satan lurking
in the background who's also got a
filial relationship with the highest
God.
It makes for a confusing kind of
theology because in many situations,
of course,
Christ is identified specifically with
God the father,
but Satan always lurks in the background
and his.
His existential status is indeterminant
because since God is everything,
then it's very difficult to make the
case that the evil spirit isn't a
derivative of God.
It's not easy thing to get straightened
out rationally,
and I think Milton in paradise lost as a
very good attempt,
makes a very good attempt to explain
exactly what this might mean,
how there could be an overarching
transcendent power and there could be
two subordinate elements to that one
evil in one good without destroying the
idea that God as such as good and with
out eradicating the reality of evil.
Very,
very complex argument to make.
Now the notion of evil is also very,
very complex idea,
so if you look at our arguments that
support atheism,
and I've mentioned some of these like
Ivan's argument in the brothers
Karamazov where Ivan says,
well,
the world in as such experience as such
must be evil because it's predicated on
the blood of innocence,
the suffering of children.
The fact that there's vast injustices in
the world is indicative that there is no
such thing as a good God or to speak
unless personified terms is evidence
that the structure of experience as such
as an untenable morally,
it shouldn't be because it's predicated
on suffering.
Jeffrey Burton,
Russell,
who's written a whole series of books on
the nature of evil,
makes a very clear distinction between
different categories of terrible that I
hit.
I think help bring this into clarity,
so imagine this.
Imagine first that it's useful to make a
distinction between tragedy and evil.
Okay?
Now tragedy is when the bad befalls the
good an earthquake is tragic.
So or diseases tragic.
Now it's easy to regard a disease or an
earthquake as evil as well,
but the problem with that is that
doesn't seem to be any motivation to it,
and so it's more likely,
it's more reasonable to think something
like,
well,
people are vulnerable.
They have to be vulnerable in order to
give existence a viewpoint.
One of the consequences of their
vulnerability is that they're
susceptible to tragedy.
Okay.
If their vulnerability is a precondition
for being,
then the fact that they're susceptible
to tragedy isn't necessarily an evil.
It's just a consequence of their
limitation.
Then you say,
well,
what constitutes evil?
If you can't put earthquakes and
diseases and so forth into that
category,
well then it seems to be something more
dependent on choice,
which is the argument that Elliot is
making.
Say the world does all sorts of terrible
things to people,
but there are frequent.
It's frequently the case that people act
in such a way to make things worse
rather than better.
Right?
So if you look at the consequences of
the rise to power of the Nazis,
for example,
doesn't seem reasonable to put the Nazi
concentration camp in the same category
from an ethical perspective as the
earthquake,
right?
Because the earthquake is and emergent
consequence of the rules that governed
physical existence.
Whereas the Nazi death camp is something
that was planned.
It didn't have to be.
It seems to be an aspect of choice and
this seems to be the idea that's lurking
underneath both this mythology and now
he had his comment on it.
It's
the mere fact that the world is
terrible,
does not mean that it's evil,
but then when you look at specifically
human actions,
there's this aspect of twisted choice
that fry also makes much of.
It says,
if you.
If you look at the structure of human
history and you try to explain why it
has such a bloody and terrible course,
it doesn't seem sufficient just to
attribute it say to the conditions of
existence or to ignorance it.
It seems more like there's a force
behind it,
so to speak,
manifests,
say,
and every individual that's actually
aiming at the suffering instead of just
allowing it to happen or instead of not
stepping in to stop it,
but actually aiming at it.